what's up what's that I'm bunking in uh
you gave it oh and that finger she
travels on the whole map yeah yeah
search erase the tram alone
Oh da da da get my tag I am going ham
huge massive did it beg for the squad
that train so good who do you think is
bear our other epsilon I'm glad to see
us because I'm a lot more people and
we're gonna say episode now honestly I
wanted to believe that we play our best
and they put their best will come out on
top I also do I think I'm dash is my
opinion on unburnable is here this is
not good I'd pick up a weapon
no this meant was great but coming in
the middle is just a debt 70 got picked
up I'm gonna go with a tram Cape imposed
okay thank prices
no Cory mother dog
okay I got to sleep in any door getting
ah the guy just drive by disqus register
I don't know I'm not taught this map
just feels very convoluted to me there's
a lot of corners and places to look I'm
gay right even dying everyone's using
sounds everyone loves a ghost go all
right into the tram out of the tram damn
it